[Music]
if we want to think about girls sports
we need to invest in the girls that are
actually playing these sports you know
the Mary Cain's but also the girls
behind Mary Keany in the race we need to
make sure that we're protecting all of
them and I think that's gonna involve
first of all investing in science a lot
of the science that we do have is based
on a boy's trajectory it's different
than a girls trajectory and then really
educating coaches to understand how to
nurture specifically a girls athletic
trajectory and then finally helping
girls at like understand what's good and
what's bad a lot of this pressure from
girls comes from themselves like these
are really good girls these are high
achieving girls they know how to do what
it takes what they don't understand
necessarily is what the stakes of that
are and that if they just ride out some
of these challenges that are different
than the boys or even some of the girls
that they're competing against at any
given time they can come out the other
side and maybe be one of those you know
women in their late 20s or early 30s
that are setting the national records
that are on the metal podiums that are
you know going to the Olympics and the
longer distance races but I think so
much of that talent is actually getting
to extinguish far earlier than it should
be if anything that's come out of this
conversation you know around the stuff
in recent days if anything comes out of
that I hope it's that that like you can
excel without hurting yourself
that's lindsay crouse and this is the
retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey people how's
it going how you doing we're all alive
and breathing so that's good I suppose
right all I know is that every day
presents opportunity and when I can step
into that mindset I get a tiny chance of
dealing with whatever obstacles are in
front of me life man we're all living it
right did I introduce myself my name is
rich roll this is indeed my podcast so
settle in and let's get things rolling
quick reminder between now and January
31st we're running a limited time
special discount on the plant power meal
plan are $20 off the annual $100 fee
when you visit meals rich roll calm and
enter promo code power 20 at checkout
this is the final week people your
opportunity to gain access to thousands
of plant-based recipes at your disposal
totally customized based on your needs
grocery delivery and grocery lists
integrated into it it's an incredible
comprehensive program so check it out
$20 off through the end of the month ok
today's episode is I think the perfect
extrapolation on the important themes
that we explored in my last conversation
with Lauren Fleshman the advancement of
women in sport fairness athletic parody
and and straight-up girl power advocacy
our cypher for today's masterclass is
lindsay crouse lindsay is a producer
editor and writer at the New York Times
if you've been paying any attention to
running news the past couple years or
just big headlines in general then I
would imagine you're definitely already
familiar with Lindsey's work as she has
broken some of the biggest stories in
recent memory some of her most popular
pieces include the sheelane effect which
she wrote about chalene flanagan and the
elevating effect that she has had on
other women lindsay broke the piece
about how Nike does not guarantee female
athletes a salary during their
pregnancies or immediately after giving
birth she produced the piece in which
Allyson Felix told her story around Nike
and pregnancy and she was responsible
for the bombshell Mary Kane
that entitled I was the fastest girl in
America until I joined Nike which is all
about the abuse Mary suffered under her
former coach Alberto Salazar and and
that piece landed as the 42nd most red
piece on the entire New York Times for
2019 in addition I'd like to add that
Lindsay also worked with last week's
guest Lauren Fleshman on Lauren's
November New York Times op-ed entitled I
changed my body for sport no girl should
and that is a must read for everyone
especially any and all female athletes
out there I'm super excited about this
I've really wanted to talk with Lindsey
for a long time and I can't wait to
share this conversation with all of you
but first let's acknowledge the awesome
organizations that make this show
possible
they say it takes two months to form a
habit and if you're making a resolution
this year that can feel like a very long
time to wait to see results with calm
all it takes is five minutes a day to
feel better calmer and ready to face
whatever this year throws at you calm is
the number one app for sleep relaxation
and meditation and calm has soothing
music from artists like Sam Smith guided
meditations breathing exercises and so
much more to keep you relaxed and
de-stressed they also have sleep stories
which are like bedtime stories for
adults I love those things and they can
help you fall into a deep natural sleep
in minutes with stories narrated by
iconic voices like levar burton and nick
offerman sounds pretty nice right are
you ready to go if you are go to calm
calm Ford / rich Rolle and you'll get a
limited time offer of 40% off a calm
premium subscription that's 40% off
unlimited access to calms entire library
with new content added every week get
started today at calm calm forward slash
rich roll we're also brought to you
today by Harry's you know what makes a
really great shave well I can tell you
it doesn't come from flex balls or
heated handles which are just tactics
leading brands used to raise prices a
great shave comes from a sharp razor and
quality design that's it and Harry's is
a return to
that essential quality craftsmanship at
a fair price Harry's team combined a
simple organ ama cos I know with five
sharp blades manufactured in their
world-class factory in Germany they cut
out all the middlemen and shipped
directly to you saving you money and
time are you enticed well all you got to
do is go to harrys.com ford slash roll
and new customers will get five dollars
off a trial set that includes a five
blade razor weighted handle foaming
shave gel with aloe oh and a travel
cover just go to harrys.com for slash
roll to start shaving smarter today and
finally we're brought to you today by
quip what do you suppose is the most
important thing when it comes to dental
care well I can tell you it's not $200
toothpaste made with rare ingredients
it's not a blue tooth operated
toothbrush it's your habits people that
means brushing for two minutes twice a
day and flossing regularly no matter
what brand you use flat out period and
quit makes the whole affair simple
starting with an electric toothbrush
refillable floss and anti cavity
toothpaste equips electric brush has
sensitive sonic vibrations with a
built-in timer and 30-second pulses to
guide a full and even clean plus and
here's the best part in my opinion quip
delivers fresh brush adds floss and
toothpaste refills to your door every
three months with free shipping so your
routine is always right it's pretty easy
right oh and quip starts at just 25
bucks if you go to get quick comm slash
rich roll today you'll get your first
refill free that's your first refill
free at GE tqu IP comm slash rich roll
ok lindsay crouse a couple other really
interesting things about her in addition
to breaking these gigantic stories she's
also a super fast runner she recently
clocked a blazing 253 marathon which she
was preparing for when we did the
podcast which was back in mid-october
amidst all of these crazy stories that
she was breaking it's an unbelievable
feat another part of the job at the New
York Times that Lindsay is involved in
is producing optics and
shooting the fabulous one on New York
City runner memo which you guys should
check out we talked about that today and
walk run ChaCha which just received an
Oscar nomination last week in the
documentary Short subject category so
Lindsey first came across my radar
several years ago when she popped up in
my friend Casey nice that's vlog and I
thought who is this really fast runner
that writes for the New York Times so I
started following her way back men
before a lot of this amazing work on
female athletes has come out and I'm
just delighted to have the opportunity
to sit down with her so today we dive
deeper into many of the issues discussed
with Lauren around women in sport we go
behind the scenes on the Mary Kane
Alysia montaño and Allyson Felix stories
Nike and its relationship with pregnant
athletes the controversy swirling around
Alberto Salazar and the Nike Oregon
project why almost all current sports
science is based on men and harmful
coaching approaches to girls and women
in sports and of course we go into
Lindsey's personal story what makes for
a great journalist great journalism what
it's like to work at the New York Times
and our post truth fake news culture and
how she manages to absolutely kick ass
and running while also being at the
vortex of breaking these huge stories I
can't say enough good things about
Lindsey and the amazing work that she
has been doing so again it was an
absolute honor and pleasure to sit down
with her at the New York Times during a
visit to New York City last fall so this
is me and Lindsey Kraus
[Music]
well pleasure to finally meet you
absolutely great to meet you too I've
been really inspired by the work that
you've been doing for a long time so
this is delightful I'm in the New York
Times for the first time which is very
exciting for me yeah things I know about
for you but it's cool to be here and you
know I've been spending a lot of time
trying to wrap my head around like what
you do and and what it means and I think
what's so compelling about the work that
you've been doing particularly recently
is that you're not only breaking these
really important stories these stories
then go on to have this life of life of
their own like there's been some really
viral moments which has to be very
gratifying for you as a journalist but
also beyond that it's not just oh we
caught lightning in a bottle like these
are important pieces that are creating
conversations and then even beyond that
I think it's fair to say are are really
creating a power shift like a shift in
the power dynamic of sport that is
empowering women to not just reevaluate
and rethink their relationship to sport
but to seize the reins of control and
power and you're seeing this community
kind of congeal and coagulate around
these ideas at least online and I know
in real life and we're in the real world
and it's kind of an incredible thing
yeah I think it's been really it's been
surprising frankly to see just how much
traction these stories are getting and
not only among the athletic community
but kind of in the broader public
discourse I don't remember the last time
the you know a politician was tweeting
about a track and field athlete or a
marathon runner and like really wanting
her to get you know maternity coverage
or to have a coach be nice to her I
think like you know decrying abuse that
in so many ways so many of these stories
are there so tolerated there so almost
normalized that they do just feel common
and it's amazing to kind of
see to kind of give the opportunity to
some of these women or young women the
chance to say this happened to me this
is my story what do you think about it
and the rest of the public is saying
actually this is awful this is wrong we
don't want this to happen to you and I
think that's been really important I
mean people say all the time the
athletes you know need to use their
voice but I think the first step is kind
of recognizing that these rules weren't
made for you and you've been following
the rules and you've even been thriving
in in these you know in in this paradigm
that has certain rules but ultimately
they weren't made for you and you want
to rewrite those rules and that's what
these women are doing and I think it's
been amazing to see all the public
support they're getting for that yeah I
mean it's one thing to say you have a
voice you use it and it's another thing
for that voice to show up on the pages
of the New York Times it really
validates that that voice has merit and
and should be heard but I can't imagine
that that you even in your wildest
imagination that a story you know about
you know you know Mary Kane who's
somebody that unless you're you know
immersed in track and field you have no
idea who this person is would connect so
profoundly with a mainstream audience
yeah and I think that's really where I
felt a lot of responsibility with her
story you know I was telling I work I
work with a bunch of men here in my
department and they didn't know who she
was I I was old enough to be her older
sister I think you know definitely knew
who she was as she was coming up in high
school I was already working but I'd
already kind of gone through the
n-c-double-a I knew what all those
systems were like and she was an
exciting person to watch but I think a
lot of athletes um you know faster
athletes than me but then also someone
like me is like oh we know how this
story tends to go we don't always know
the details of why but we've lived our
own lives and you know it we all have
kind of very few athletes you're lucky
if you've just had if you're a female
athlete and you just had kind of like a
straight shot and been successful the
whole time I think that can happen for
men more but it rarely happens for girls
and I think when we did see Mary
you know leave Nike I'd always wondered
what happened to her and not unlike
uh-oh I forgot about her I think I
actively wondered about that a lot but
when she told me her story I wasn't
surprised because it tracks so closely
with stories that a lot of female
athletes and you know women whether
you're an athlete or not have
experienced on some level but I did feel
a lot of responsibility of taking the
details of her story many of which were
not that surprising and kind of
translating them to the general audience
and saying look you need to care about
this and we're gonna we're gonna show
you this and then you can be the court
of public opinion right and it was
amazing to see that people cared about
that the story her story is outrageous
but it's also representative of a story
that so many women have lived yeah
undoubtedly well for people that are
listening who perhaps might not have
read the story it probably would be wise
to kind of set the stage or
contextualize this a little bit sure so
Mary Cain was the fastest girl in
America which is how we had her open the
peace I mean this was back in sort of
the early aughts and so she was the
fastest girl in America she was setting
so many national records and she was
sort of like the darling of the tracks
teens she was supposed to be our next
Olympian Alberto Salazar the best coach
in the world on the best team in the
world by the best company in track and
field in the world Alberto Salazar the
coach at Nike of Nikki Oregon project
he called her up when she was 16 and was
like I want to coach you and it was a
dream come true and I think that's
what's so important to remember she was
living the dream that every every high
school or athlete wants to have every
parent wants for their daughters and
that's why we had to kind of get people
really excited about her rise so then
they could understand why her ascent her
why her descent is so so striking and so
important she went out to Nike and she
was 118 pounds kind of varying between
118 and 120 won this is at an age when
girls are you know flat like flush with
estrogen which is a performance it's not
a performance-enhancing hormone by any
stretch of its having girls you know
gained a little weight they're running
there
etc and meanwhile boys are getting their
like kind of oozing testosterone which
is a total performance-enhancing hormone
and her coaches are telling her you need
to lose weight
she's 118 pounds she needs to be 114
pounds and they are not telling her how
they're not telling her how to do this
safely and so she starts you know trying
to lose weight however she can think of
and she loses her period and that's when
the injuries set in this is what happens
to girls when you diet too much lose
your period you your bones start to
break your body starts to break down and
ultimately she started engaging in
self-harm suicidal thoughts and she had
to leave and she has spent the past few
years with dealing with that injury
cycle of broken bones and it's awful and
what's particularly awful to me is that
you know there are other athletes in the
past like melody Fairchild for example
these are all like the best girls in the
country and we just assume that that
they burnout and we don't think about
the idea of what certain coaching
approaches are doing that in Kurt that
actually caused that burnout instead
right and this is this is in plain sight
absolutely it's not it's it's different
than doping scandals because there there
isn't even an effort to obscure it
because it's sort of systemically
accepted as protocol yeah and I think
that's what's so important about her
story broadly is that it really shows
that we need to start thinking more
about if we care about girls sports
which so many conversations right now
are establishing that apparently we
really care about the future of girls
sports I do seems like a lot of people
do it's not about necessarily some of
the other conversations that I think are
distracting from that like for example
transgender athletes like those are very
separate conversations if we want to
think about girls sports we need to
invest in the girls that are actually
playing these sports you know the girls
that the Mary Cain's but also the girls
behind Mary keen in the race we need to
make sure that we're protecting all of
them and I think that's gonna involve
first of all investing in science
there's not a lot of the science that we
do have is based on a boys trajectory
it's due
thundergirls trajectory and then really
educating coaches to understand how to
nurture specifically a girl's athletic
trajectory and then finally helping
girls at like understand what's good and
what's bad a lot of this pressure from
girls comes from themselves yeah like
these are really good girls these are
high achieving girls they know how to do
what it takes what they don't understand
necessarily is what the stakes of that
are and that if they just ride out some
of these challenges that are different
than the boys or even some of the girls
that they're competing against at any
given time they can come out the other
side and maybe be one of those you know
women in their late 20s or early 30s
that are setting the national records
that are on the medal podiums that are
you know going to the Olympics and the
longer distance races but I think so
much of that talent is actually getting
to extinguish far earlier right I mean
the the changes need to be systemic top
to bottom but there also has to be this
perspective shift in that we need to
pivot away from this idea of you know
short-term gains and and you know kind
of operating like a publicly traded
company operates on quarterly profits
like that's all that's as far as your
vision extends and look at the long term
like the law that what's in the best
interest of that athlete over the course
of an entire career and look it's
somebody who who you know I'm older I'm
from a different generation but I've
been around sport my whole life and it
wasn't until kind of sitting down I sat
I had lauren flashing around my house
recently and then reading her op-ed
piece that I know you were instrumental
and helping put together am I starting
to realize like the vast differences
biologically with women with respect to
this of this this estrogen cycle like
this like with men it's like it's a
linear progression of getting better and
better and faster and faster right
that's kind of like the paradigm and
with women once you reach your late
teens and your early 20s you you have
these body changes and then changes
later in your 20s that you know put you
in a very different place and and better
understanding that is what's required in
order to really you know have that best
interest at heart for these girls yeah I
mean I think I mean there has been a lot
of scrutiny on
after the Mary Kane story and in some
ways the response has been a little
disappointing because it's like I don't
think it's all about just having an
investigation into the abusive practices
of coach Alberto Salazar I think this is
again he was just doing what a lot of
men do what a lot of women do because a
lot of the women that you know make it
to the point where they're a coach have
come up through the system as well and
had to endorse it or at least survive in
it I'm to the point where they don't
necessarily see anything wrong with it
if they see something wrong with it they
would leave probably and I think it's
it's kind of perhaps studying some of
this stuff and actually saying like you
know for Nike a multi-billion dollar
company to actually say we're gonna to
be a leadership force in this like we
started the Girt we were a big backer of
the girl effect back in the day we were
marketing our shoes off that and really
inspiring girls what if we follow
through and actually fund some research
how much money would that cost that much
and the the optics but also the outcomes
I think would be really powerful and I'd
love to see that it seems like such an
easy leap like I don't understand why
that's so difficult for them to wrap
their heads around like when I look at
the pregnancy leave issue which we can
get into in more detail on a revenue you
know on the on the revenue tip like it's
nothing for them to support these women
throughout their pregnancy and when I
first came across the story I thought
well this must just be an antiquated
clause that's just been in a contract
forever and nobody mmm you know took the
opportunity to go hey we should change
that yeah versus you know like just that
kind of support would pay dividends a
hundredfold because of just the
storytelling potential alone about that
support yeah I mean I think especially
when what really struck me about that is
that you do have athletes and you have
had athletes like Cara couch' Alysia
montaño who would always struck me about
what they managed to do was that they
came back better they still came back in
one metals and I think that was amazing
and it would always bothered me was a
you know I'd kind of known what they
were go
they're a little bit back back at the
time that they were doing it and it was
you know how to fully investigated it
but it always bothered me that it was
that the hardest part should be winning
the hardest part should not be fighting
your sponsors for the chance to do that
or feeling like you belong in the arena
at all like those should be the things
that we are we should be paving the way
for women to try this we should not be
punishing them for trying and I think
that's why you know Allyson Felix was it
was a big source on that story obviously
didn't feel comfortable necessarily
sharing her story in the vulnerable
position of having just had a newborn
and being in the middle of a contract
negotiation but I think that really
resonated with a lot of people that I'd
reached out to her because I thought she
was gonna be the person that said as you
did that it was probably an antiquated
clause and that I was like surely
Allyson is getting whatever she wants
and the idea that she too was having to
fight and feel feel like the hardest
part in addition to of course the you
know coming back for an emergency
c-section
it was fighting her sponsor for the
chance to do that and I thought that was
so sad it is I mean what uh what's even
more kind of like amazing and courageous
and powerful are are the current
athletes who are now speaking out
there's this woman Tiana B yeah wrote a
blog post she's currently sponsored by
Nike right and spoke out against her
sponsor like I can't imagine like that's
that's like a very ballsy thing to do
yeah one thing that was really amazing
about the maternity coverage in general
and that's been great about seeing kind
of the dialogue around you know abusive
tactics because again the idea of abuse
is subjective like the idea of rights
are subjective and when the story around
so we did two pieces around what we call
dream Maternity and it was sort of an
answer to to the dream crazy campaign
which again it was it was just calling
out contradictions between marketing in
reality in video form and through the
voices of athletes themselves who were
you know unfettered by they were
breaking their NDA is basically to talk
about it
and I remember after we put out the
piece with Alysia montaño and Kara
Goucher who were kind of older at like
they they were no longer sponsored by
Nike when they talked about this
although the NDA still applied I had a
few women who were more recently
sponsored by Nike that called me and
they were like you know actually I
didn't have a bad experience with Nike
like I was fine so I just really want to
tell you that um even though maybe the
company isn't binding itself to support
me they supported me and I'm very
grateful and I well thank you for your
feedback and then Allison feat Felix we
shared her story a week later and I got
so many calls back being like wait a
second I didn't know I had rights like I
didn't know I could get this and that I
didn't have to be like grateful for it
and I thought that was what was so
important that yeah it really is women
almost like realizing that what they
feel lucky to get is actually maybe
something that they should get and again
that maybe they can just focus on
winning instead of fighting for the
chance to do that yeah in the process of
putting these stories together like the
research and what kind of like work that
goes into it
how difficult like what was the the
process the journey of getting these
women comfortable to talk about their
NDA's I mean that's a very dicey thing
yeah it was really hard I think in
retrospect it looks like it all was
exactly the way we premeditated it for
or that we planned for it to be it was a
lot of work I mean if you talk to Alisha
who was kind of the first person to say
I'll do this it's a really emotional
thing for her to talk about and there's
a risk so I basically like wrote I had
to and the challenge for me is that you
know I'm taking all these emotions and
all these feelings and that's not what
we're doing what we're actually doing is
showing some facts and showing the
audience like this is what happened this
is what the current situation is so you
have to sort through a lot of this
really dance like this is someone's
entire life and their family and that's
really hard but you can't overwhelm the
audience with too much you really need
to kind of signpost for that like this
is the story this is what happened and
so I think we were really sorting
through a lot of the
of that emotion to try to tell an
objective as objective story as possible
with a little bit of opinion mixed in so
that was hard and then with Mary it was
sort of the same thing it was like okay
so here's your experience we need to
catch an audience up who doesn't care
about track who has no idea who you are
and help them understand all of these
different things in a very quick way
that kind of gets straight to the
emotion but but the emotion only matters
if you understand the facts and so
that's what it's returning right so on
the the pregnancy maternity story did
that come to you or is that something
that you were tracking down or paying
attention to like how about originated
yeah I wouldn't say that anyone that
participated and that was particularly
excited about doing you know I can't
imagine yeah it was a lot of trust and I
was really grateful that the women did
wind up trusting me because I did feel
like I was trying to get them I was
stirring up something for them that they
really didn't want to think about and
you know trying to ensure them that I
could get people here to invest in it to
the point where it would be worth it
because they're taking on a huge risk
and I didn't know if people were gonna
necessarily care about this or not but
so that that was a story that originated
probably back in 2014 when I was I just
wrote a story for our Sports Desk here
I've always been a producer in opinion
but since I'm a big distance runner I've
always I you know I see what's around me
and I I always wanted to kind of write
the stories that I wanted to read and so
a lot of my friends maybe like four five
or six years ago we're starting to have
kids sort of like the first wave of that
and a lot of them are really good
runners and we were kind of watching I
was watching everyone do this and I was
watching noticing that they were coming
back and sometimes being like faster
afterwards and I was really excited
about that and it kind of mirrored what
we were seeing certain elite athletes do
like Kara Goucher for example was
following in the footsteps of Paula
Radcliffe and everyone was kind of
touting like oh this is so amazing and
so I wanted to write a story where I was
like
kind of showing the trickle-down that
continues to really excite me about
American women distance runners where
you see you see like Kara doing this in
the New York City Marathon and then you
see all these other women doing this as
well even though they don't have
sponsors and so I interviewed Kara and
elysia at that time and I was like so
like what's the hardest part and they're
like well the physical part is hard and
then they were off the record like we
don't get paid for this at all don't
print that so I think I printed a really
broad sentence about it if you know was
no no attribution and no one cared about
it so everyone was like wow this is
amazing like these women are doing great
like no one was worrying about the other
parts okay we're getting paid like it's
not interesting to anyone and then you
know as I got older here and I'm kind of
watching other stuff here like I have
this um Boston opinion Adam Alec who was
like okay you do all this stuff in
sports like you know this really well
like good things come from things that
people are passionate about so why don't
you move the needle on some issue here
in sports like in a way that you care
about and I just remembered kind of that
line from Kara Goucher and her agent
Shanna Burnett and I was like I'm gonna
see if that's still true wound up being
a lot harder than well I knew it was
gonna be hard and it was really hard I
can't just be like hey send me that no
no no is it some kind of like all the
President's Men situation yeah in a
parking garage and somebody hands you a
manila envelope um I had some agent show
me emails like in front of me um and I
could take a picture with them like with
my camera phone and so that it wasn't it
wasn't traceable to anyone else because
I mean again yeah I've totally
sympathetic to the idea that this may
not be the biggest political issue to
people in the entire world but these are
people's lives and people's families and
Nike is a very litigious multi-billion
dollar corporation like people I was
extremely sensitive to the idea that
people were scared of that company and
it sounded like they had every reason to
be
which made me need to be even more
diligent to back them up and so by the
time I actually had emails from people
decline from
you know sports marketing executives at
Nike declining to put paternity
maternity protections in writing into a
contract it was like well this was sent
three weeks ago so so we have this yeah
but that that was a really long kind of
connect the dots of how do I figure this
out how do I figure this out who do I
talk to who won't go back to the sports
marketing executives and tell them that
I'm doing this and then they somehow
undermine the story or gag everyone from
talking to me
you just don't know and I'm doing it all
here from New York so it was like kind
of a like late at night conversations
with people but given the fact that
you'd slipped it into that earlier story
and no one seemed to comment on that you
must have thought that you know you're
rolling the dice with this larger story
about it like is anyone gonna care
mm-hmm yeah and I mean caricature was
like fine you can quote me but could
your lawyers also please defend me if I
get sued by this company and we can't do
that here at the Times I'm all we can
tell all we can tell an athlete like
that all nerble person up against you
know a company like Nike all we can say
is that if Nike Sue's you for exposing
that they didn't pay you for however
many months while you were working for
them because you had a baby we can put
that on the front page of the New York
Times that isn't bad look yeah but no
but I can't tell you technically they're
within the rights to do that she
breaches she breached the NDA yeah of
course yeah and I I was worried about
that I really didn't want these women to
get sued or suffer at all for kind of
exposing their truth and ultimately it
was hard to because they kept being like
you know we might do this but nothing
will ever change and I don't I didn't
know if anything was gonna change all I
could do was get the story out there and
see what happened but then in August
John Slusher and an executive vice
president of marketing there did send
out a memo to all athletes saying
immediately you were covered for 18
months with no performance related I
mean as a journalist it doesn't get
better than that it was a real world
change as a direct result of your
reporting yeah and I think what was what
was even most important to me was the
symbolism of it
this idea that all the ways that women
are struggling or kind of know that they
can or can't do something and they're
almost like changing their behavior
around these rules it's like instead why
don't we change these rules and I love
that the times can be a part of that in
terms of being the force that might you
know get Ivanka Trump and liberal
senators to both call out on Nike and
say you can do better than this I mean
the next best step would be to maybe
change some actual laws because all of
this is totally legal and I'm not sure
that it should be up to an individual
company to decide whether women should
be able to have children and still
support themselves but failing that it's
really exciting to see that the times
can be a part of actually getting people
excited about these issues that a no one
wanted to talk about in the first place
or didn't feel comfortable about and be
that people weren't necessarily going to
care about unless we kind of told it to
them in the way that was really gonna
resonate mm-hmm yeah I think you know
the fact that Nike and Salazar are woven
into all of this kind of makes it sexy
for a lot of people but it's myopic to
just perceive this through that lens
like it is a bigger it's a systemic yeah
right like I came up in swimming my high
school girlfriend was being sexually
molested by my school coach since she
was 13 years old and she was like number
two in the world at 200 butterfly was
meant to make the Olympic team in 88 and
fell on her face at trials because she
was emotionally traumatized by this and
it kind of came to light what was
happening by that time I was already in
college and this was like 1986 mm-hmm
snow 1997 1988 and and it was settled
out of court for a paltry sum it was a
different era and then it didn't come to
light until much much later because the
Washington Post cottoned on to the story
and knew something had happened and
wouldn't let it go and finally got Kelly
to speak on the record about it right on
the eve of like that
Olympiad and then he went he went to
jail but like this was like took like 20
years for this to get sorted out and so
I guess my broader point is that I grew
up around like we all knew who the swim
coaches were who were doing this kind of
thing so whatever Salazar did or didn't
do like this is going on all over the
place with all kinds of coaches in all
different sports yeah and again I can't
emphasize enough that what's going on
with Salazar there was totally legal
it's like there's nothing
techno one's ever said that there was
actually something wrong with what he
did it's done by so many people it's not
sexual abuse and I think it's really
really important that we expand our
definition of what's right and what's
wrong to kind of open it up to other
things like this like this emotional
abuse like you know in court like almost
forcing a girl to change her body to the
point where she's breaking it these
things are all so bad and I think it's
I'm really heartened by the idea that
people are finally starting to come
around to that yeah there was a very
interesting tweet thread that I saw
recently in the wake of your story
by Stuart McMillen who's a prominent
track and field coach and and strength
coach and he kind of just said like look
I'm saying this you know I want to ask
this in good faith like is there is it
ever appropriate to talk to a female
athlete about weight and it kind of
created this thread and I think you know
I'm giving him the benefit of the doubt
like he's really what he wants to know
like what is the answer to that question
understanding that that weight is a
factor in performance and the solution
can't be that we can never even bring it
up we just have to find better ways and
more educated ways of navigating the
vicissitudes and the the kind of you
know emotional landmines that this
creates for young women absolutely I
mean I don't really have a strong answer
for that either aside from what you said
but I do think I do think two things one
is that what you said about education
for
which is really really important I think
in the case of Salazar it's pretty clear
that it wasn't that what he was trying
to do this arbitrary 114 number was kind
of grounded in his own beliefs not in
any sort of science right yeah yeah and
I think that's what that's a real
trouble with what with what a win at all
costs culture shows with like letting
almost like megalomaniac culture a cult
of personality dictate what the outcomes
as opposed to science so the first thing
is education and making sure that
coaches are making educated decisions as
opposed to just kind of like personal
preference decisions and imposing those
on their athletes that's really harmful
for athletes but the second thing again
is I think improving the science and
really making sure that whatever science
we're drawing upon we've we're clearly
just at the tip of the iceberg when it
comes to a woman's athletic or
biological development in terms of what
we understand and how it relates to
athletic outcomes and potentials so I
think we really need to be studying that
more if we're serious about the future
of women's sports right and more women
coaches yeah and more women owned you
know apparel company like who are the
people who are in power who are making
these purse-string decisions about the
athletes that they're going to support
and what is that what is that climate
and dynamic look like yeah I think if
we're gonna get actually serious about
women's sports we need to have more
women we can't just have women
participating in those sports we need to
have women in positions of power in
those sports that connects to coaches
that connects to administrators and
officials that also connects to the
women telling their stories there are
almost no female reporters and sports I
mean we should really be thinking about
that as well I think is it like 4% of
sports stories are about women's yeah
and that has to be because of the
reporters like I mean if how many
stories are there about baseball that's
baseball and football yeah which is
important but I think I think actually I
mean my my dream in terms of like what a
what a great career like I see it would
be for this this stage of my career is
almost to go back and people tell me
this is unrealistic but America was
really captivated
track-and-field back in the Steve
Prefontaine era like that was kind of
the dawn of the sponsored runner in the
first place and everyone was so excited
about him and what he represented and
I'm wondering you know at this stage
especially as we see like with the
series that we're doing at the x equal
play people are really talking about the
sport now in part because of the women
that they're listening to and how we're
highlighting what the women are going
through and accomplishing in this sport
and disrupting in the sport how that
connects to the rest of our culture in
our society and I'm like what if we
actually put women front and center in
this coverage of the sport could we get
Americans to care more about this sport
which I love and that's really
influenced my life drastically in ways
that I could have never anticipated when
I started doing it I mean if you look at
how fast the American women are from the
professionals on downward now there
actually has been a trickle-down effect
in terms of women getting faster and
faster and I think Americans should be
looking at this more and really getting
fascinated by this and I think like I am
living and breathing this right now like
it's half of what I think about I'm sure
my bosses are thrilled about that um and
I just I wish that we could be telling
that story more and getting more
Americans excited about about listen in
the sport all right well the wish is
being fulfilled Lyndsey cuz I Got News
for you like this is happening like and
you're a big reason why it's happening
like we're having this amazing moment in
women's track and field and marathon
running I don't think there's ever been
more mainstream interest in these
incredible athletes than there is right
now because of the performances you know
with des linden and SH Lane and these
incredible marathon performances and
then all of the kind of social and
cultural issues that swirl around this
that is I think you know really like
gluing this community of women together
which makes them all the more powerful
and interesting to the public as well
yeah I mean I think that's also been a
really cool opportunity here at the
Times is that think all these people
necessarily all these women necessarily
knew each other ahead of time like for a
dream eternity they weren't connecting
to each other about
so it was really just me kind of being
like I need a voice I need a voice I
need a voice will you talk about this
and not everyone would but some people
would and those were the women that we
wound up being able to showcase to the
times audience as a chorus and it was so
much more powerful with all of them
together and then you know
Alysia spoke and then Kara spoke because
Alesia was leading the story um so she
she felt secure and telling her story
then Allison spoke because she saw the
reaction to their story and then when I
was talking to Mary she was like I want
to do what Allison Felix did you know
Mary grew up worshiping Alice and
obviously like everyone everyone Mary's
age most decorated track athlete of all
time speaking out about something beyond
the track that was actually influencing
her and changing something Mary was
inspired by that and I think that's been
really amazing to see that we can do
that here at the times we can be a forum
for changing some of the seventh
bringing women together and then seeing
chalene come out you know as this newly
minted coach who's trying to you know
shift this culture and you know she
didn't mince words and she was very
clear about the changes that need to be
made and what her aspirations are and
then Lauren flush men's op-ed like these
are like you know these are like big
moments
absolutely yeah I mean I think I think
shillin's reaction to the Mary story was
really powerful I've I've always been
really impressed as an athlete and a
journalist but particularly as an
athlete you know I've watched chalene
and what she's done for her teammates in
terms of you know almost being a career
catalyst for these teammates and making
them really successful like a woman
hundred percent success rate of getting
her the athletes that she's trained with
to the Olympics um you know you could
say that's their coach Jerry but they
don't have the same success rate for the
men on that team and so you could really
attribute the success of that team to
chalene and I think it's easy to to
cheer for the positives and I thought
that it was really really strong of her
especially when she was just kind of
anointed as their first female coach
which is really exciting for the
industry but it was it impressed me so
much that she spoke up and said I don't
want this to happen anymore and I think
cultures evolved and cultures change and
I
sounds like she's really trying to be
someone that moves that culture in the
positive direction on the Mary Kane
story Mary approached you yes right yeah
as sort of on the heels of seeing your
other reporting and feeling like this is
the person that I need to go to to share
this with yes oh I didn't know her um so
we we had to kind of work together to
think it was hard like at first she just
kind of wanted to do it fast I was like
no I think we really want to spend some
time on this we don't want to bucket it
with any other marathon coverage was
hard for me because I wasn't sure how
much people were gonna care but I wanted
to take the time and really invest the
effort in figuring out how we could do
it in the biggest way possible that
would get the most eyeballs I wanted to
have it be her telling it in her words
ideally on screen um because I think
that's by far the most powerful way to
tell that kind of a story and that kind
of thing just takes a little bit of time
so we we were working on it for I'd say
maybe like six weeks or something um I'm
really glad that we waited and that we
didn't do it along with other news but I
think it was psychologically difficult
for her to to wait knowing that she
wanted to soon it I think it's like as
soon as you decide you want to get
something off your chest you want a gun
but I think in the end the payoff was
worth it oh for sure I think what's
interesting is that you know I would
imagine a lot of people are under the
impression that you're just a full-time
writer on the Sports Desk covering track
and field and it's actually not your
main gig like you're you're at op Doc's
right like producing video is like kind
of your main that's your main gig isn't
it yeah and part of your job
yeah I mean I think my story tracks
pretty closely with a lot of the women
that I write about and that you know I
came here as an assistant maybe like
eight years ago and I was told at the
time that it wasn't a position where
there was a path to promotion but I've
been working for Jody Kanter before that
just like helping her as a researcher on
her books she's the woman that wound up
breaking the Weinstein story we're kind
of starting Limi to movement and
she's a real feminist and I I I'd worked
for other people before and no one had
ever been like here's how you can get a
job which is kind of what you obviously
want when you do those kinds of things
and so she helped me get one of those
jobs here and I was just like okay so
there's a two-year expiration date on on
how long I can be an assistant here and
I got to start got a start now and so I
just kind of started doing everything I
could to get promoted so optically just
started it was right when the times was
I'm getting more um more experimental
before that the institution had really
been sort of you are this and you can
only write this way and so I've always
been kind of like scrapple II trying to
figure out how can I get the things that
I care about into this paper and as it
is visible away as possible but without
necessarily having like the full-time
role there and doing that and so I
started freelancing for the sports desk
a lot but was kind of at the same time
getting promoted in optics this short
documentary series it's very like kind
of festival oriented like we do you have
a lot of Oscar films a lot of Emmy films
so I'm doing that but then at the same
time like building up this body of work
about the sport that I really care about
and also seeing that a there's an
audience for it like people really care
but be they're not really getting done
and they're getting done but not
necessarily in the way that I would do
them because I've really lived these
stories I've lived Mary's story and in a
certain way I've at some point you know
I've watched my friends experience the
maternity thing and listen keenly and
think about what how that might
influence my own life as I move forward
I think you want women telling these
stories about women I mean my sense is
that you're you follow your curiosity
it's not like oh here's the story like
Oh report on this it's just what are you
interested in and then continuing to
pull on that thread and say yeah you
know something is revealed
yeah I mean I think I've often had a
skill at translating very specific
stories about about something very niche
like running for example which I think
people sometimes will say oh it's just
running and I'm like well you're only
saying is just running first of all
because I'm writing about a woman
usually
and you're not maybe seeing like how I'm
getting to like this bigger idea but I
always look at it as a challenge of like
how can I take something about running
and make it something that you know
Kamala Harris is going to tweet about or
that someone will find you know in in
inspirational and surprising and
challenging and I think that's what I
tend to love about the sport and it's
actually yeah it's been an amazing
creative challenge and a real pleasure
to get to share it with others but but
no I'm not on the sports desk so when a
story comes to you or you're developing
it what is the decision tree in terms of
like this would be good for an op doc or
this is just gonna be you know in
editorial or long-form editorial piece
like how do you decide like this is one
we want to tell visually so none of the
none of the things that I've done for
equal play have been op Doc's actually
abducts is a series of short
documentaries by independent filmmakers
and so I'm or the curator of that series
and again those are the kinds of films
that we're sending to the Oscars or the
Emmy Awards um it's it's something
different altogether what I've done in
equal play is actually out of this new
opinion video franchise at the times in
opinion and that's started by Adam Alec
who's like the executive producer and
then on these videos I've worked with
Paige Jensen Jensen Alex Stockton
Naima Raza I just like really really
smart video producers here and for
myself I I think what we're doing an
opinion video is actually a fascinating
new form of journalism that it's been a
real pleasure to kind of help pioneer
and spearhead I think more story should
be told in video it's only a matter of
resources and I think hearing something
from someone especially when they're
breaking news has been you can't
substitute for the written word I am NOT
a writer here in opinion but I do write
from time to time and I think those
stories are more just the ones that like
I come up with on my own and I'm just
like this needs to happen now but when
it's someone else's story I I don't
think there's any substitute for telling
it in their own
words yeah who was that what's the name
of the guy that is the super fast
amateur mm oh yeah yeah yeah but that's
perfect oh yeah because like you watch
that video and you fall in love with
this guy right it wasn't it wasn't
perfect because we had to really script
around him English is not his first
language and it was that was a
fascinating creative challenge this was
a video about a Mexican immigrant to
America who came here and documented I
think like back in the 90s he crossed
the border and started to seek his
fortune in New York and you know worked
a bunch of sort of working-class
blue-collar jobs and always very
scrapple E and at the same time became a
runner he was a bad runner back in like
Pueblo where he's from he like was not
good on the track team at all but
somehow when he got here he flipped a
switch and you know never with any
particular amount of resources but he
got really really good and he just ran a
228 at Boston this year which is I think
it placed him like 9th in the world for
the majors rankings and so you know I'd
like found out who he was and I was like
okay so I don't want to just do like the
here's this guy's story I wanted I want
to see if we can almost like feature him
especially right now because there's
such a debate around immigration I'm
like wouldn't it be funny - not funny
wouldn't it be important to to have a
formerly undocumented immigrant who
makes almost no money teaching us us
being Americans who you know have
relative privilege compared to him in
many cases times Times readers tens
viewers what if he taught us how to
succeed because that's not the narrative
that we're seeing all the time ours is
more like a should we let them in should
we not it's not like oh what can we
learn from them why should we respect
them and how are they beating us and I
think those stories are hard to find but
when you do they I think they really
surprise and delight people
well it's absolute gold I mean he's just
you know stripped down like basically a
menial laborer who has no resources
whatsoever and just does it for the joy
of it and is just about the basics yeah
right yeah it makes you realize like Oh
everyone's what what should I get and
the new
running shoe review and all of that is
just nonsense yeah which I relate to I
mean I know ten of money to spend on
tech either but that's what part of what
I like about running it's like you can
be making you know like thirty thousand
dollars but like I was when I first
graduated from college and you can still
run like no one's gonna kick you off the
roads or out of the park it was great
but if that was an example of a great
collaboration here in the department
where I just had the sight I had this
guy and have this idea and I want to
somehow comment on like fit spoke
culture and about some of like the
performative excesses of of exercise I'm
working out these days and about hat
like what I love about running which is
like getting out there and run so I have
this guy and I'm like he doesn't think
any of this necessarily like he does but
he's not gonna like deliver an oral
argument about it so I'm like how do we
do this and so again my colleague Naima
who goes to a lot of boutique fitness
classes and as a genius I got her to
start thinking about this and then max
Kanter who also made the dream maternity
video with Alesia which again he like
conjured the emotional rhetoric of a
Nike ad like that's really cool and then
tej Jensen another producer up here like
he had a he had a video reference for
what what could inspire the the concept
and like with all of our minds it turned
into that and it was like the most
popular item on the on the New York
Times for for forever and I was like
such a pleasure to again have a formerly
undocumented immigrant at the front like
effectively on the front page of the New
York Times for a weekend for something
really great like something that he
accomplished as opposed to like a
hardship that he's endured I think it's
also emblematic of the beautiful running
culture of New York City like you you go
running in Central Park and there are
people running in there that are for
real like you're like wow that those
people are real runners and it's
incredibly ethnically and
socioeconomically diverse yeah and and
there are these running clubs like isn't
that part of your story to you when you
came here and you kind of fell into one
of these clubs like it's it's very
working-class and egalitarian and
and you know bonded by just nothing more
than like this shared love of running
yeah and performance and community yeah
and I also love I mean there are all
these races here and it's like it is
people from all over and like all
different backgrounds who are doing
really well in these races and I think
memo and his team the west side road
runners the west side runners they are
really representative of that like you
don't hear from them very often like
partly because a lot of them English is
not their first language and I don't
think they're on Facebook and Instagram
the same way that you know a different
demographic might be but they're doing
so well and we need to hear those
stories too because just like we can
admire does Linda nourish Elaine
Flanagan we can admire these people too
for other reasons yeah 2:28 is no joke
yeah I found him I found that really
impressive and it's like more people
need to hear about this - yeah how is
Mary cane doing now I would imagine like
you know the spotlight on her has got to
be super intense and my sense just is is
that like she's kind of not hiding but
just keeping a very low profile well
this conversation is happening yeah
she's done she's done a really great job
I've been really happy with how she's
managed to conduct herself because
there's so much stress there and I don't
think she's particularly media trained
the night before we finally released it
I felt so bad because I was like I don't
want to tell you that this is gonna be
really widely read because it might not
be um but if it is you need to prepare
yourself because I know when we did the
dream eternity for for example with
Eliseo metallus enlike it was a lot but
but they were older and they had I'm not
a team but they had more people to help
them I think and Mary didn't really have
anyone so um I shouldn't tell her agents
she was doing it so yeah it was like it
was pretty I think she was just like
getting forwarded all of these things
but had no one to help her navigate any
of the media requests I was trying to
help her but that's also not appropriate
for me to be like you know actually
telling her what she should or shouldn't
I shouldn't be advising her I was just
trying to help her navigate some of that
stuff and she was keeping it together
really well now she's
got Alice I've connected with Allyson
Felix his brother so now he's
representing her and he's really savvy
West Felix and I'm actually gonna talk
to them in like an hour and I'll
probably hear more yeah so I first I
think he first came across my radar it
was several years ago and I think it was
because you popped up in Casey's vlog oh
yeah friends with Casey for a long time
Oh awesome and and I'm like who is this
really fast runner who works for the New
York Times so I like I think I started
following on Twitter a long time ago so
this is before like all these big
stories were happening and so I did you
like Casey did an op doc yeah I met
Casey yeah that would have been like
seven years ago or something at this
point maybe eight years ago I he texted
me for my birthday this year died
Facebook had brought up a really old
picture of us from like 2011 or
something where he brought a birthday
cake to an optics event for me because
it was on my birthday and I was like oh
you're always you're such a loyal kind
friends like thoughtful very much is
that yeah and I he's moved to LA now and
I really miss him because I really loved
running with him there would often be
times where I'd be running on the west
side and like some guy I'm oblivious
when I run and some guy would like turn
around start running with me and I got
oh it's Casey
yeah and now I'm gonna be asphyxiated
because he's so fast and I can't breathe
but yeah he's he's an incredible Runner
and a wonderful friend I have this habit
before he moved that every time I come
to New York you know a couple times a
year and I just you know I get up
whenever I get up because at the time
change and then I go run along the west
side and I would say like maybe like
seven out of ten times I would run into
him like I don't plan to go running with
him but I'll just I'm like I'll bump
into him yeah he's running all the time
yeah whatever
but now that he's in LA I haven't run
with him once cuz he broke his
collarbone yeah yeah that's so sad no
it's funny it'd be funny to like turn up
on his blog because I would not say that
I'm camera-ready
I'm always like very complimentary about
your and you know you you merit that
because you're super fast you're getting
ready to well the goal is to run an
Olympic Trials qualifier yeah for the
marathon i i'd always i mean so my best
time is a 257 and that was a six-minute
PR that i ran last year i also had like
the cycle of injuries or whatever came
out of it and then it was almost like
you know i had maybe like four years
where i kept trying to get like faster
and faster each time we get an injury
and an injury and it would be awful and
then suddenly i realized i wasn't even
trying anymore and i was really sad
about that and then it was almost like
by letting go i was like why don't you
just try to make a starting line and
that was maybe three years ago or
something and I did make the starting
line but I wasn't doing anything like
fancy in terms of training and I ran my
best time ever and so I was like oh this
is amazing I can do this again and so
then I'd always wanted to break three
hours and last year I did break it um at
at see I am California International
Marathon and which is almost like it's
it's such a runners race it's it's very
there aren't a lot of professional
runners there's not a huge prize purse
it's just people that really love
running and are trying to run as fast as
a Sacramento yeah it's it's amazing and
um and people are traveling from all
over the country it's mostly Americans
it was a really really positive feeling
so I did break three hours then I
remember in a 257 last year and that was
a six minute PR so then I thought maybe
I could run another six minute PR this
spring and then another six minute PR
this fall unfortunately I got injured
right away and instead of forcing it I
was just like how about I do some of
this work here and actually like cover
this like this the stuff that I wanted
to cover right about running I can't run
and then I finally started training in
July and I started to get faster and
faster and it's been amazing but then
actually it was around when I was doing
the Mary Kane stuff and covering the New
York City Marathon like the memo video
there was a week where I think I only
ran like 40 miles or something and had
to drop out of a workout
and I was gonna just like drop out of
the whole thing oh no this one working
yeah I definitely I don't know if I can
tow the line at the race you know I
missed that one workout yeah this guy I
don't know if you know Mario Fraley but
yeah he he put you just been a podcaster
than that he put up so I test I was like
I can't believe you beat me you know
Lindsey Oh funny see her this week he's
really great but um you can always tell
that my state of mind is for better for
worse I'm sorry for anyone who follows
me on Java but how I post on Strava and
just have existential it's getting and
there was some workout where I dropped
out and I was like I just really need a
coach so I'm like trying to do my track
teams workouts but I'm also doing higher
mileage because that's how I get faster
and he texted me he's like hey I'll help
you and just like kind of advised me a
little bit and then when I had to drop
out of these workouts like more recently
I was like maybe I'll just do Philly or
maybe I just won't do anything he's like
how about you just relax so neurotic
so that races in a couple weeks now yeah
yeah so that's uh that's in two and a
half weeks now so I what is the what is
the trials qualifier 6:17 and that's
gonna be a stretch so that is - what
does that come out I'm sorry - 44:59
yeah so but it's amazing to see how many
women are doing that and I just thought
again it's like you watch everyone doing
these crazy things like a lot of us
weren't that good in college like but
we're getting better now and it's like
why don't I just go for it and what's
the worst that can happen I fail and
either totally fail or run a PR and so
now I'm hoping I can break 250 which
would be just unbelievable so I'm going
to Philly this weekend and I'm gonna try
my race pace has been all over the place
so we're gonna see if I can get some
detail so you ran in college you ran at
Harvard
yeah yeah cross country and track yes
you did yeah and and you were like what
like what was your relationship to
running at that point it was um uh
complicated I when I was in high school
getting into Harvard was hard for me I
really wanted to in a real laughy for
anyone but getting in I think so for
other people I was really amazed when I
hadn't heard of like Yale or Princeton
I'd heard of Stanford but I was like
from that kind of a background where
it's like you've heard of Harvard and so
you or did you grow up in southern Rhode
Island which is the backwater that I'm
portraying it as at least like where I'm
from I heard of Brown probably I'd heard
of Brown but I didn't know about hey
guys no seriously I just didn't and I
think I'm just not from that kind of
background I guess where like I didn't
know anyone that went to Harvard and no
one from my high school had gone to
Harvard so I was just I was a pretty
competitive student loved running was
always like I'll stay ish kind of for my
final years in high school and really
wanted to run in high school I mean
sorry in college but wasn't recruited
anywhere and got into Harvard and then I
was like whoa I'm so scared about this
which kind of makes sense if you think
about it and I was like I'm not gonna be
good enough like oh this is really
happening
yeah and well-known just more like I've
now I'm in the big leagues like you've
got to keep up and I was like okay
anything I lack in talent I'm gonna make
up for with discipline like I've gotta
gotta get like ready for this I was just
so scared for it and classic yeah no
totally and so I'm fortunate Lee part of
that so I was like I'm not pulling
another all-nighter for for math anymore
and just started like putting all that
effort into running and again it's like
with the Mary Kane story like girls like
I didn't have a coach that was telling
me to lose weight but I just always felt
like there was a simplicity
you're not skinny like the other girls
and I was like again yeah what I don't
have in talent I can do with discipline
and I lost like 30 pounds in three
months or something 20 pounds you posted
that picture on Instagram awesome
yeah I've never I've never been so
miserable and it was like what I thought
was always so sad to me that it was a
time when I should have been really
excited and proud of myself but instead
just kind of turned it into like what
else I have to do kind of and I think
that's something that a lot of girls
face and that's partly why Mary Kane
story is so important to me that we need
to kind of highlight
some of the pressures that these girls
face but that was a short-lived episode
for you yeah a difference being there
wasn't a coach lording over you like
affirming that or telling you to you
know go even deeper in yes yeah I was
very lucky that that didn't happen and I
was really lucky especially that when I
did get to college I was so excited that
that was not the culture there um and
that the girls weren't like that and
they almost like we're very anti that
and so I just very quickly changed I was
like I want to be like these girls so
I'll be like them they're healthy
they're happy you know to the extent
that anyone at that school is and yeah I
just changed so but I think it's I think
it's also it was good to get that out of
my system and not wonder like do I need
to work harder uh-huh so then what was
your career like in college athletically
yeah um I just wasn't good and I mean
the Ivy League is really competitive for
distance running I was varsity my
freshman year and after that I just kind
of went through the cycle of injuries I
got a stress fracture on my back like a
my SI joint into sophomore year couldn't
walk it was just like what is this sport
that I thought was so great for me why
is it hurting me now like why is it
ruining the rest of my life and I was
kind of going through that I think a lot
of people you know if you do come at the
other end you have a complicated
relationship with running at some point
and I definitely did and I think you
probably lose a lot of the sport
probably loses a lot of people in that
period and so I wasn't competitive then
but was almost like the system was just
so I think I just needed to be done with
it and need to needed to do it on my own
terms and that's what moving to New York
was for me so so did you run all four
years though um I ran until so freshman
year was the only year I ran seriously
sophomore year I was completely injured
junior year I ran and then senior year I
ran cross-country and then did my thesis
for the rest of it but then when you
moved to New York you picked it right
back up so it wasn't like I walk away
from this for errors and then like I
kind of rediscover it later yeah no I
was up I've always run but definitely
not not in the way that a lot of other
women my
my level run which is much more
consistently and I think you're being
hard is that type a thing again I think
he'd the reality of that might be a
little bit different from your
perception yeah can always be our
biggest critic but then you move to New
York and and you kind of discover this
community right that like you know
rejigger is your relationship to the
sport yeah and I think for me what I've
also loved about running for me has
always kind of in times it's been about
control but at other times it's been
just totally about freedom and about
being able to do whatever I want however
I want to do it and I love that as
opposed to you know the teams that I've
been on where you're really supposed to
do things a certain way here and I think
Casey's actually a lot like this it's
like I can just do whatever I want
whenever I want from a running
perspective like why he keeps getting
injured yeah but I've always really
liked that about him specifically with
with regard to how he approaches running
in New York and I sort of do to where
it's like I run with my team when I want
to run with my team I back off when I
don't want to run I run a lot when I
really want to achieve something other
than that I'm just like generally
running I mean other times I'm not it's
like I can just do whatever I want
because I'm not a professional runner
and literally no one cares right except
right now when you miss one workout
well yeah but you can't feel like I
think that's also a really healthy thing
that running teaches you is that I'm
actually struggling with us at work
right now because I feel like I'm just
working all the time and running all the
time but it's that you go really hard
and then you back off and I love that
about distance running I love being able
to measure your life and those cycles
and having these build ups and then I
come down and then a break it really
build up again and it's like what I
don't like is when the build ups that I
come up with are interrupted by other
factors but it's got to be cool now
because of what you do professionally
that you can like hang out with all
these amazing women runners right like
you get to like run with your heroes
yeah I try not to look at it like that I
think I think as soon as you become too
much of a fan you you kind of lose track
of what you're doing but you did write
an article called the sheelane effect
yeah but I don't think that was um I
don't think that was a fan article I
think that was and I have a lot I think
that was a I really respect what this
woman is doing and what she means for
the sport it wasn't like a chalene
Flanagan please be friends with me
article um and I think that's I think
that's a really important distinction
actually is to not not want athletes to
like you but just to kind of pay
attention and try to see them in a way
that is actually very serious and almost
like critical in a positive way but I
didn't look at it as a as I love this
woman it was more like I look at this
woman the way that I looked at at the
team captains and college and have deep
deep respect for what she's doing
and almost treat her like a CEO yeah I
get it I mean that's the difference
between journalism and being a podcaster
because I can like fall yeah yeah yeah I
do try to kind of be as as objective as
possible and I did think that was an
objective article of course I can't help
like you know I mean I'm here we're here
in the New York Times I've never been in
the New York Times before it's
impossible for me to like walk these
hallways and kind of look at what
everyone's doing without thinking about
the current climate of journalism in
this era of you know quote-unquote fake
news and the New York Times is that
corrupt and like you know all of that
kind of stuff so that that is just
percolating in our you know kind of
political climate what is the experience
of actually working here and what is the
you know how do you like you and your
colleagues here kind of deal with all of
that you mean being and being a national
pride yeah sort of being like the locus
of that particular yeah that's been an
interesting evolution because when I
started here in 2008 I was joining an
institution that I had always wanted to
be a part of and that in particular I
really wanted to approach as a place
that I could help change like in
whatever
small ways that I could and I think I've
definitely accomplished that both
through optics like now through the work
that I've done an opinion journalism and
in particular at this point like how I
am approaching Female Athlete it's I
think that it's been of really
astonishing trans trans ition
professionally to suddenly working for
you know an institution that I've always
considered to do really really honorable
work that is sort of more you know
viewed by some people now as an enemy of
the state which which it sounds
obviously not um I think it's it's
really kind of redoubled my commitment
to the mission and in particular I think
it's it's helped me to kind of see more
of a purpose and especially the work
that I'm doing around female athletes
were in a in the midst of a very very
important cultural conversation right
now and I think in some ways my
professional experience has mirrored
some of the women that I that I write
about in terms of you know not always
feeling like I have the seat at the
table that that you know might go to
someone who's a more like usual suspect
like in sports reporting for example and
kind of showing like like the again like
the rules that we thought were the rules
or the ways that we think things are are
actually different now I think the times
is trying to help drive that
conversation that the culture is having
partly in response to the upheaval that
we're in right now yeah I mean it's
gotta be annoying what do you mean just
the idea that people are saying that the
fact that there's like arrows being
slung at the New York Times like this
the pinnacle you know this sort of the
the gold standard of journalism I don't
know I mean I I've had some friends who
you know I think that they are they
perhaps had more personal risk when
during the election that they were
taking on you know by having Trump come
to come to power but I did have
conversations with them at the time
where I thought if if the election does
go that way we need to have that
information we need to know that this is
where the country is right now and
perhaps during the years before that we
were certain people not every not every
person but
certain people were able to overlook
that and I think these conversations are
being forced now and there is gonna be
some pain around that there is like do I
like that our bathroom now is lockable
for in the case of an active shooter no
I would hope that I'll make it in there
first you know before someone that locks
the door like do I like that we're
having active shooter drills now and you
know the security is where it is no of
course not but at the same time I think
that you know stability doesn't usually
lead to change volatility as disruption
does and so I guess you can try to see
it that way right even though even
though it's difficult and it's painful
and I I know other people are having
even more of a painful time than I am so
I'm really thinking about them not me
yeah I would imagine you're you probably
can't talk about stories that you're
actively working on right now but what
what are maybe some of the stories that
you would like to see told that you're
not working on or things that you're
seeing out in the culture that are
interesting and you feel like could use
a little bit of a nudge or brighter
light I mean I have a never-ending cache
of stories particularly around women's
sports right now I'm dying to do more I
just need the opportunity to do more on
broadening outside of running and track
and field though so many of these issues
are so relevant in other sports well I
actually think that's I think um I think
it's actually gonna be really good to go
narrow at first especially when you know
something narrowly really really well
because that's um that's creating this
really broad conversation that I think
is extending outside of in a world you
really understand yeah I think but that
being said the next thing that we are
going to do is I don't mind saying it's
about coaching and I am obsessed with
the idea of the idea the title that led
to it put more money in women's sports
and so ironically men took all the jobs
like before title nine girls were
coached by women because there wasn't
any money and then after title nine
there was money and so now it's like
less than fifty percent of women's teams
are coached by women
and I mean obviously men's men's teams
are coached by men yes I'm hoping that
the amazing treatment that we're gonna
give this this piece is going to really
get people excited about that idea and
it's just so it's such a paltry ask to
change that the I mean this is like just
in the n-c-double-a I just want to work
on that what's your perspective on the
shifting landscape around compensation
for NC to a amateur athletes I think
it's a positive thing I mean yeah I
think with all of these things these
systems are all built in a way that
favors men like the the only reason that
people are even talking about that is
because football players and basketball
players obviously that favors women
women rarely have a lucrative
professional league to go on to in the
first place so if they do manage to
break through like Caitlin did in
college it's only fair that you let them
make money off of that at the time yeah
so she did some crazy floor routine yeah
right and the video went crazy volley
said like a hundred million views or
something like yeah it was really really
widely watch and she just looked so
joyful and I think that's what's so sad
about it is that you're like you're
watching someone do something so great
and they're not being paid for it and I
think that happens a lot I think it
especially happens to women and I it's
it's very it's I think women more often
are told you know I stuff sometimes when
people are like oh did you have fun and
I'm like why did have fun but I also
didn't get paid for it and it's it's sad
it's insane so now we have gavin newsom
with this new yeah their fair play to
pay fair fair play to pay to pay to play
act which is lining up to you know now
it's setting the stage for perhaps a
battle with the in situ way it's gonna
be interesting to see how this evolves
yeah everyone always says it's like
Nikki right everyone always says never
underestimate their lack of willingness
to be bossed around to change I'm
inclined to think the public perception
is so in favor of the athletes right now
that it's that it will be upheld but I
also do not underestimate the
two doublea's eagerness to to undermine
it to the extent possible but I think
it's an inevitable eventualities like
legalizing marijuana like the the
cultural tide has shifted on this one
and whether it takes a year or five
years to get that done I see it
happening no matter what yeah I mean I
would have to blow out this analogy but
I think it's a little similar to before
when all of these systems were built for
wealthy white men and college sports
existed because wealthy white women were
going to them and they were amateurs
right like the if you look up amateur
athletics the first hit you get is like
a Harvard Crimson article from like back
in the late 1800s it's like that's what
that's what amateur athletics was and
that's also why the Olympics was why you
couldn't make money if you were an
Olympian for a really long time again
this was for like gentlemen athletes
this is not for poor people who are
using these sports to make money and
ideally to catalyze their lives through
these sports and to economically
catalyze their lives and and the reasons
the systems are resisting that is
because people don't like the idea of
the sport itself changing not because
they not because they're actually
engaging with the fairness of what would
be best for the athletes that are
currently dealing with the currently
suffering from the ramifications of
these decisions what are some of the
other big changes that you would like to
see in women's sports um you have to
think about that I mean I think right
now the biggest thing that I'm obsessed
with is about the idea that everyone
wants girls and women to participate but
when women really run into problems and
again this is why I think you can talk
about track but this is everywhere this
is in soccer like this is in sport this
is like I'm thinking of government right
now yeah I think it's that okay like I I
was so upset watching the women's
women's national team in the World Cup
this year because I was in high school
when brandi chastain had that amazing
picture on Time magazine and of course
it was on the cover of news we get my
parents has it was like girls rule it's
like okay we'll overlook that this is a
30 something year old woman like and
that you're calling her a girl on the
cover of Newsweek but it really kills me
that
I remember watching that and this was
when I was back in high school and I
wasn't necessarily on a path where I was
gonna necessarily be successful just by
default the guy was needing to do that
for myself but people were saying you
can do whatever you want and what
bothers me is that that was true until
you become an adult and a woman and
you're working and you want to be paid
for it even now in my case are you yeah
I can still do whatever I want I can do
all these stories it's when I want to be
paid for it and actually like have this
be my job that's when you run into
trouble I think that's what bothers me
so much about watching the Women's
National Team is they are having to work
twice as hard they're having to work two
different jobs and be perfect at it in
order to even make the case for equality
in terms of wage and even then it's only
equality and that's exactly the same
thing that I've experienced in my life
and in my career and I can't stand that
this is unfolding for all of these good
girls like again we are telling this to
like girls all around the country like
work really hard and then like it'll all
pay off for you and that's not the truth
and that yeah well there's this crevasse
between the marketing images or the
marketing messages versus the reality
behind the scenes of what's actually
going on yeah yeah it's like screws
again it's you can tell girls that they
can do anything I mean like even when I
was in college it was amazing Harvard it
was out of resource constrained
environment and so they made sure
everything was equal because we weren't
fighting over resources we weren't
trying to get I wasn't trying to get
more of a wage than my male peers it's
only when you start to get into the
workplace the girls start to experience
this and that's the same in professional
sports girls do not have women do not
have the same resources and they have to
make the case of they have to they have
to be perfect in order to get what they
deserve it kills me yeah we gotta round
this out in a few minutes but I'm
interested in your thoughts on what what
makes for a great journalist like what
do you think are the qualities that are
that are most important in in telling
meaningful stories I think a curiosity
is really important being interested in
figuring out that what someone tells you
isn't the whole story generally speaking
um kind of asking questions like I think
that's where equal play has been really
interesting is
coming up with people what people don't
know and what they're not thinking of
and telling that story that's I think
that's important from a journalist
perspective it's almost like not being
so it's almost like why your question
about like do I want to be friends of
these athletes like not really I want to
know them and know what they're doing
not not necessarily like like them so
much that I can't you know be objective
anymore and I think that's a really
important distinction for a journalist
like figuring out what the questions
that aren't being asked and getting to
the bottom of those and then also being
independent and kind of like self driven
enough that you're not changing the
story to make other people happy you're
telling the truth yeah and I think in
terms of your career trajectory you just
seem like somebody who who worked really
hard but was very intent on making sure
that you seized on whatever small
opportunities came your way to turn them
into larger opportunities yeah I mean I
think for myself and this goes way
beyond being a journalist I've always
benefited from kind of like being
entrepreneurial about things and taking
you know taking one thing and thinking
like okay well have this one story how
can I make this like the most read story
and the New York Times even though like
I did that with like a shot put her
article I like I've asked Matt Letterman
if I could write this article about like
shot-putter say I'd always thought about
how like when we were on the on the bus
in college like with shot putters were
in the back almost living like a totally
different life from us like kind of like
going crazy and they were so fun and we
were like studying in the front like the
distance runners and I was like are
these shotput people yeah and I was like
but again like they were really smart to
like just in a different way and I
wanted I was like I wanted to revisit
that older like in a different stage of
life and see like who were the ones that
became the pros and what are they like
and it did not disappoint but I was like
I just want to I want to see like how
can I get people excited about something
that they would never think about
otherwise and I think that's always been
that's always been my creative challenge
as a again it's not like a job anyone
told me to do but I find it really
really fun a little following your
curiosity I mean I think what's been
interesting for me just just sort of
paying attention to sports coverage on
the New York Times like I was somebody
and I've heard you say this before
even though I was an athlete I don't
really care that much about football
baseball and basketball huh I just never
read the sports books like it just
didn't interest me I wasn't covering the
sports that I cared about anyway it
never occurred to me to like oh we got
to check the sports page yeah I read it
which is why I don't land it was this
bland it like whatever that's why I
don't care where my work shows up now
I'm like whether it's what section
it and yeah like the sports page can be
the sports page and I can do what I'm
doing but I think what's cool is that
there has been a really kind of unique
you know original flair to what the New
York New York Times has done with their
sports coverage and you know I'm sure
Matt isn't you know large part to be
credited for this like with really
interesting long-form stuff like the way
that that the times covered Cullen Oh
Brady's Antarctica crossing which was
written by my friend Adam school and Ike
like I thought was so compelling and
interesting and dynamic with with you
know just the the visual layout of it
and everything was just made it made
made like makes these stories come alive
in a very human interest way that
transcends just you know stats and
scores and who won the game yeah yeah I
mean I think everyone here at the times
would agree that that's what the true
true a plus sports stories are right now
it's it they're hard to pull off but
when you do it's like it's it's amazing
and I think really at its core Sports is
about limits like human limits and in
really pursuing those which is why I
think there is this opportunity to
refocus American interest on endurance
sports in a way that it's sort of leaned
in recent years it's not all just about
games all the time it's about you know
like rigorous pursuit and pushing of of
limits of human limits and I think
there's a there with that you get this
this like a quickening of the emotional
connection between the reader and the
subject right like through you can you
can see some aspect of yourself and your
potential through the experience of
whatever this person is tackling mm-hmm
yeah absolutely
which i think is cool yeah all right
well the last thing I want to ask you
about is is has to do with resources
available to somebody who's listening to
this who finds themselves in that
precarious
coach athlete situation like if there's
a young woman who's participating in
college sports and is you know under the
thumb of you know the kind of coach that
we've been talking about or finds
themselves with a dysfunctional you know
relationship with their with their body
or with food or what have you what are
some like resources or or places that
they can go for help
I don't know there's a safe Sports
initiative sort of the higher levels of
the sport and thence in the n-c-double-a
I think um your college athletics
administrator would have to care like I
I would be astonished it especially
after this recent this recent
conversation that we've had that someone
would turn a blind eye to you you're
younger your parents should care and I
but I think just arming yourself with
the medical science which is just so
readily available is your first line of
defense I think that's what's really
helped me look I knew something was
wrong with myself and I like kind of
reading about the science made me sure
that it was true also just going to a
doctor if you're an athlete like a
doctor will always back you up yeah well
also just speaking your you know using
your voice like if something's not right
like you know I think you've you've
you've given permission to a lot of
people yeah that voice yeah and and and
shifted culture such that that voice
will be heard and taken seriously yeah
and to believe themselves if they think
something's wrong I think again I've
fallen into this trap I think a lot of
really driven especially girls who are
obedient they're really good I think
they fall into this trap
you think that hurting yourself as part
of what you have to do to be good and
that's not true and I think if anything
that's come out of this conversation you
know around the stuff in recent days if
anything comes out of that I hope it's
that that like that you can excel
without hurting yourself yeah well it's
been a pleasure talking to you no thanks
keep doing what you're doing please like
it's incredible and your name comes up
time and time again on the podcast and
I'm always like pointing to the work
that you're
I think it's really important and it's
very impactful and so I just wanted to
like publicly acknowledge II for that
like it's it's it's been super it I'm
not I'm not a woman athlete and I'm like
emotional about the work that you do
like I really do think it's it's it's an
amazing thing so thank you for that
service and and wind in your sails and
244 244 yeah thank you I appreciate that
and I'm I really appreciate you sharing
it because I definitely wouldn't still
be doing it if people weren't paying
attention so let's go right well thanks
so much so if people want to connect
with you I mean they can just they can
find all your articles in the New York
Times and you're lindsay crouse on
twitter and instagram right yeah
anywhere else
I don't know are you gonna write a book
yeah in my sleep
you're so yeah after you qualify for an
Olympic trial yeah yeah yeah I'll take a
rest thank you thanks so much if you
come to LA well I'll get Casey and wall
go running together that would be
amazing I would listen yeah okay next
time peace
so that happened we did that I think it
was pretty powerful stuff hope you guys
enjoyed it please be sure to check out
the show notes on that episode page to
learn more about Lindsay and the great
work that she is doing and show her some
love on the socials you can find her on
twitter and instagram at lindsay crouse
li and DSA y Kraus CR o us C of course
you can find her work in the New York
Times and I'll put links to a lot of her
pieces that we discussed today in the
show notes if you'd like to support the
work we do here on the show subscribe
rate and comment on the show on Apple
podcasts share the show on social media
tell your friends about it subscribe to
my youtube channel Spotify Google
podcasts and you can support us on
patreon at rich roll com forward slash
donate I want to thank everybody who
helped put on the show today Jason
camiolo for audio engineering production
show notes and interstitial music Blake
Curtis and Margo Ruben for videoing and
editing the video version of the podcast
although that did not happen today
because I did this one in New York City
without Blake and Margo so no video
today in any event Jessica Miranda for
graphics Allie Rogers for portraits
typically but not today again because
she wasn't with me in New York City
DK David Kahne for advertiser
relationships and theme music as always
by analemma appreciate the love you guys
see you back here in a couple days with
the phenomenal Rickey gates ultra runner
artist performance artist writer
filmmaker photographer this guy does it
all truly a beautiful human and here's a
clip to take you out until that piece I
think the Appalachian Trail is awesome
like there's no doubt about it but like
you're gonna learn a lot about yourself
and you're gonna learn a lot about trail
culture but how much are you really
going to learn about the United States
in this greater context it's it's a form
of escapism and that sometimes exactly
what we need is to escape what's going
on outside of our front door but for me
personally like I needed to explore
something a lot deeper than just myself
and just the physical capabilities of
something like that so I mean I don't
know what
benefit is but I know that there is a
benefit stepping outside of our comfort
zones and looking people in the eye and
and I think it works both directions I
think that it makes those people feel
more human you know when you're sleeping
on the street in the middle of downtown
LA you you can feel less and less like a
human and it makes you and me feel more
human as well and tap into this empathy
that I think can go a really long way in
our you know in this time in our society
and something that perhaps we're losing
a little bit and it's a good way to to
kind of gain it back a little
[Music]